is being told what to do something that
bothers you in all areas of your life
are we is this happening now when you
are in a room with me therapy is always
happening
they were doing group therapy I'm super
amped on this I've never been in therapy
but I'll do it I don't know what it's
about but I'll do it I don't really see
the point of it what could go wrong what
could go wrong so many things I'm dr.
Jenn hi dr. Jenn welcome to therapy yeah
maybe shooting right down each other why
relying on me for the analysis but you
know I do what you become for me on him
I think therapy is super useful and not
something that anyone should ever be
afraid of so what do you do I'm a shrink
I do individual therapy couples therapy
family therapy and group therapy this is
almost like work therapy you probably
eat together you talk in between shoots
together we've slept together yeah yeah
yeah coolest kind on the bullseye yeah
the bougie times we're great friends we
work together a lot we work together
really well but I don't think we're
perfect and I'm really excited to work
see you know are there underlying issues
why should I pay someone to talk to me
when I could just talk to someone when
you sit down with a professional very
neutral person if you ask your mother
your father your best friend one of
these guys everyone has their own agenda
in your life even if it's positive when
you see a professional they don't have
an agenda what if I feel like I'm doing
really good I think I'm pretty perfect I
believe everyone has room for
improvement strong men talk about their
feelings bro I think a lot of people
think that I'm the most conceited tri
guy because of my hair I think keith is
the most conceited I'm Keith of the try
guys aka
Justin Timberlake of NSYNC we're on
camera a lot doing bit I hope people
think I'm so cool I'm so down-to-earth
but a lot of Keith's funny stuff is
about wanting to be the center of
attention almost to the point of being
kind of conceited the crowd just
screamed bloody murder just by being
beautiful Keith and the rest and it
makes me uncomfortable everybody's
really talented and try guys on what
they're good at I think that my skills
are probably lower than everyone else's
on the things other than performing so I
play more into the performance aspect
because that's one of the things that I
do think I'm good at did you know that
about him know what I didn't know that
about him I had said something difficult
to Keith
he wasn't defensive he kind of was very
introspective about it I think you are
one of the best performers if not the
best you know it's hard to bring up a
concern you have with somebody but I'm
glad that he did so that if there's
something I can change then I'll change
it
I think Zac should be more confident I
sometimes feel like I need to say like
three times as many lines of them just
to get one good quote in when I was a
kid I was not good at anything else like
that's why I started doing creative
stuff and that's part of why I was
depressed like I hated doing sports
that's how you're cool you're either
cool cuz you play sports so you don't
play sports you're not cool so I wasn't
cool wait transition they're out of zach
that's got to be one of the worst
transitions I've ever seen on American
Ninja Warrior zach has a tendency to be
really worried about stuff I'm not a
nasty man I never have been and I no
problems about that are you guys scared
to get hit absolutely don't you have
problems about that that's like I would
have so many problems with that what's
the alternative when you say you know
I'm not that masculine guy not that
strong guy I think that you're stronger
than you give yourself credit for I
think he gets in his own way sometimes
I'm never confident in what I've done on
a shoot I always just see the thing that
I didn't do right when you obsess and
beat yourself up it ceases to become
productive or as if you're able to take
and go okay this is how I grow as a
performer well then it's actually kind
of a good thing that it happened
[ __ ] dr. Chen Ned should be more
comfortable being himself in more places
I'm a manager with a lot of other
responsibilities feel like I don't
always have as much time to commit to
doing try guys projects and I end up
working extra balance I think would be
would be good for Ned so I talked about
Keith earlier and I was thinking about
it more as we were talking and I think a
lot of it stems from me being pulled in
a lot of different directions both in
work and in family life you're actually
being role model to these guys when it
comes to being in a relationship I'm
Mary that is married as [ __ ] kind of
wife my wife and I miss my wife we are
thinking about having a baby I sometimes
get anxious but I'm not being as much of
a contributor to the group as I can and
have to compensate for that you guys
know that he felt that way I mean he's
in a really tough place and I think it's
really admirable how much he's able to
do I'd like for you to look at your
schedule and kind of go okay where can I
have some downtime even if it's 20
minutes of vegging out you know playing
computer games or just like hanging out
with your wife I think you need to start
inserting those into your life so that
you don't resent other people I have an
ironic sense that therapy is explicitly
designed for people like me who don't
have access to their feelings gotta push
that wall down Eugene's gotta have his
walls pushed down you have a little bit
of a rebellious spirit a little bit have
you electrocute anyone's taint before no
I know my god it's worse I feel like you
shut me out Eugene is one of the most
uniquely talented people I've ever
encountered I feel like a lot of the
time when you know Eugene takes a lead
on Annette if he doesn't want our help
and he doesn't want us to get involved
in it it's a little hurtful did you know
he felt that way I am aware that I shut
people out during creative processes you
could even be missing out on things from
these three guys that might make your
next video even better so you were
saying that you don't like to be told
what to do yeah
agree with that my two sisters were I
know we were highly competitive we
improved the month and finally the
prettiest sister but as a family it's
kind of like the underlying expectation
was just to be better than everyone else
it must been a lot of park yeah yeah
so if I was going to be the artsy one
which I was I had to be the best artsy
person touch my hands fine your hands
are really sweaty you know why you do
that I don't want to be here that was
awful I get that the family you come
from you're not used to talking about
certain things so it's uncomfortable to
talk about it but my goal is for you to
leave here knowing more about yourself
than before I got Wow highly
uncomfortable I like that he had an
insight and then immediately recoiled
from it I I feel something I just don't
know what it is thank you so much for
trusting me and open up to me and for
being open to this process I appreciate
it thank you doctor thank you dr. Jane
the scariest thing I've ever done in
this series is sit down with my friends
and a woman who is just intent on
knowing more about me maybe I should
just open up all around maybe I should
go to therapy jeans favorite this is my
she's gonna be so excited oh my god he's
gonna love to god oh thank you come I
don't mind hugging dr. Jenn oh my god I
thought you're making soup oh my god
yeah
yeah